[Music]
hello chess fans I'm Isaac schrock's
just associate here at the st. Louis
chess club and I'm joined here by creamy
tahini the scholastic director this
fantastic manager this plastic manager
at our at our scholastics apartment here
and we just got back from the Moto
Museum where we held a tournament today
now the Moto Museum it's a motorcycle
museum not your standard place for a
chess tournament how did this event come
about why were we there today well we
were there because of our partnership
with the SLPs school system since last
year we've been doing chess instruction
in the SLPs schools free of charge
thanks to a very generous grant from our
wonderful board and founder and so this
year about three months ago I guess I
would make it 2017 last year
Kipp wore the one of the gifted and
talented directors in the system reached
out to us and say hey you guys do want
to do a tournament or us and that's LPS
only tournament and we were like sure
and he said great dr. Calvin Adams their
superintendent wants it at the Moto
Museum right and we were like wow okay
never think of putting a tournament
there and but then when we got there and
they explained why they wanted something
a little more special than just another
school gym he said just he wanted
something that the kids would remember
just forever and I think I think he was
right now today is a Wednesday and I I
would normally expect students to be in
school did they take a field trip today
to participate that I guess was the idea
that those kids that were selected by
the by our instructors in partnership
with the school officials at their
schools to to settle on a list agree on
a list of four to six kids Oh God to
come from the school they were allowed
to take the day off and come play chess
so it was a day where the students kind
of earned a day off by playing chess
here so yeah maybe maybe some students
could take some notes that I if you play
some chess you don't have to go to
school so much salutely I've
lutely but I'll tell you I think I have
a feeling that those kids who played
with us today pleaser I'm sure they
worked and focused just as all you have
kids in school yep absolutely I'm sure
you know and it's it's hard to lose in
chess when you're young oh it's hard to
lose right and but when you're young
especially I think the less filter is
less mm less you know defense mechanism
walls are built up so there were a lot
of there are some tears yeah absolutely
so they are do what do you think really
stands out in this specific tournament
compared to just your usual Scholastic
tournaments what was the main what's the
biggest difference that really stood out
to you today that's a great question I
think first and foremost was of course
the novelty of the venue the the
motorcycle museum the Moto Museum which
was great and if I could put in some
thanks to Colleen Barden the director
there at the at the motor museum she did
a great job for us so we for everybody
where we like you think today was a
success you like it as far as I know so
Kip wore again that my counterpart for
SLPs who we organized the tournament
together
he said dr. Adams was very very happy
and was already talking about who's dr.
Adams Kelvin Adams the superintendent is
or the st. Louis Public School System
very happy and already talking about
bigger and better for next year awesome
was there too
so I based on that I would say went
pretty well oh good well I'm glad it was
a success
I've been Isaac's Ron so this is cream
towel Unni thank you for joining us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you